Matt is with us in Pittsburgh
I'm Matt how are you hey Dave how are
you today better than I deserve what's
up well I've got a question for Dave um
my wife and I recently sold our primary
residence and bought a new one we're on
baby steps four five and six the cows
that we bought needed some work and we
are starting to work on it and I put my
head up above a drop ceiling and looked
up there and found some cash and my
question for you as somebody who is a
financial person a real estate person
also somebody who um you know somebody
who's epical but yet is not a pushover
in business uh what do we do with this
do we do we get it back to the owners
this the house say was about three
months ago I my ethics is almost always
solved by one question I treat other
people like I'd want to be treated okay
if I was the seller if you were the
seller and you forgot that you left cash
in the ceiling what would you want
someone to do what I mean if it was you
if they were if the shoes were swapped
if you swap moccasins and you walk a
mile and the other guys moccasins what
would you want them to do well I guess I
mean I want it back yeah and I would I
mean if it was thirty years ago it might
be a little different it's three months
how much cash about six grand and and
the people that sold it to you sold you
the house are they what age are they I'm
going to guess and say they're elderly
their folder I don't know if I'd say
elderly maybe in their 70s they're very
well-off financially and the truth is my
wife and I talked about it we don't need
a sixth gram it doesn't matter whether
you need it doesn't matter whether you
need it it's not yours now it's theirs
okay I mean swap shoes yeah
it doesn't matter whether they need it
or not yeah okay that doesn't enter to
the inner into the ethics I mean you're
asking me my opinion that's my opinion
okay
not chastising you I'm just saying that
that you found someone else's money that
they forgot yeah I mean if you had found
if you'd reached up there and pull down
their wedding pictures you want to call
them and give them their wedding
pictures now and we talked about that
whether it's you know this cash is going
to get the end of somebody's bank
statement you know it's not like we
found a wedding ring or something like
that
so you found something that belongs to
someone else and they forgot it yeah and
you should call them and give it to them
okay that's what I would do if I were in
your shoes that's a little bit I
appreciate it thank you Matt open up
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you will stop
a second in these situations whether
it's business or whether it's something
like that that's a nice question it's
Cosby and he's being sincere I'm not
wasn't chastising him maybe I was too
much but Kelly's looking at me like yes
you were but I'm too much coffee today
but the but the point is the if you'll
stop when you're in these things and I
have to do it too when I'm dealing with
someone who's being a twerp to me or
something like that I have to stop for a
minute and go okay I'm going to breathe
a second here and I'm going to put the
other guy's shoes on
and I'm going to walk around in his
shoes for a little while just switch
gears I mean completely completely
emotionally exchange places with them
you found a lost wallet you found $2 you
found
$20,000 sometimes the equation changes
but what would you want someone to do if
the roles were reversed I tell you you
guys that run businesses you gals that
run businesses we coach small businesses
all over America through our entree
leadership program
I tell mall that listen I can solve most
of your HR problems most of your
compensation issues how do you design a
comp plan what comp plan would you
you want now I'm going to assume that
you're a person who likes to earn your
keep you need to be worth what you're
being paid you don't want to be just
given charity and if you're one of those
jerks and I can't switch places with you
but if you're willing to work hard get a
callus and break a sweat and you switch
places with that person in my in your
mind then then how would you want to be
treated on that commission that's in
question it's question whether the
Commission is owed to the salesperson or
not when in doubt you know what I do
I've held why what highly motivated
extremely loyal sales people and when
every time there's a dispute I keep the
money they don't get it it's hard to
retain talent number one it's hard to
attract talent number two and number
three you scratch your head and wonder
why you the culture of your organization
sucks because the way you treat your
people treat other people like you want
to be treated it's the golden rule do
unto others as you'd have them do unto
you
and I've actually fired people using
that if I did that I would expect to be
fired if I stole from the company I
would expect to be fired for stealing
for the company and so you still I will
fire you I don't because Trust is broken
and I really can't I can't negotiate
with a thief and so I'm done it's not
that I have a short fuse
it's that have zero tolerance for
thieves so you steal I'll fire you I
don't care if it's a roll of toilet
paper if that's your low bar for
stealing you're a really low bar thief
aren't you if you'll still toilet paper
people you'll steal anything think about
it and so I can I can even in an extreme
crazy situation like that I can even
exchange places there and go well crap
I'd expect to be fired if I did that so
I fire him because he can't trust him
and I'm not flipping about it like that
I'm not sarcastic about I'm always kind
I'm just kind of a sad day but I'm not
gonna keep them will keep people I can't
trust organizations run at the speed of
trust
and when the integrity is broken its
broken so how do you treat people how do
you pay people when you're designing or
you're redesigning a comp plan which by
the way with our growth pattern around
here we're constantly redesigning how we
compensate things because things change
so fast what we're selling changes so
fast so how you treat your sales team
they treat the sales manager that's
getting an override how do you treat the
developer that's working on the project
well I you know I one guy come in here
and he said you know I got I got even
more degrees than a thermometer this guy
been to college his whole life I guess
and came in my office one day he said
man people that have degrees like me you
know that they're in a fortune 500 world
they make you know they make a lot more
than I'm making here and so well you
should probably go to work there because
around here what you get paid for is not
the degrees that you have around here
your raise is effective when you are so
if you learn something while getting
those degrees you actually apply that
and you cause this organization to win
because of it then you'll be compensated
appropriately but strutting around here
throwing around your sheep skins doesn't
get you nothing this is an organization
of performers I treat other people I got
one betrayed I don't expect to be paid
for my degree I've never walked up to a
customer and said you know you need to
buy my book because I have a degree he
buy my book because there's something to
say in it that'll help you now I've
earned your business that's why the
Total Money Makeover so five million
copies because it helps it serves treat
other people like you won't be treated
about the waitress that dropped all your
food right as she got to the table you
have to start the order completely over
if you read one of those days now I'm
hungry as a matter of fact I'm hangry
which is hungry and angry now right at
that point when that food you know I've
been there but but I mean how you know
bless her heart you want to be treated
how do you want be treated maybe you
need to be clear with somebody maybe
there's people you've been dancing
around the issue we have a saying around
here to be unclear
is to be unkind when you dance around
the issue and people don't really know
you're frustrated about something that's
not kindness that's cowardice kindness
is letting them know gently and firmly
where they stand in this relationship
due to their behavior that's actual
kindness
I'm not saying walk through everything
like a bull in a china shop but be clear
be clear solves a lot of your ethics
problems is Jesus stuff do unto others
as you'd have them do unto you